Let's just be honest with ourselves for
a minute.
Economics is a mind boggling discipline
for economists that's bad,
but also sort of good news because you
can make almost any argument stick if
you just troll around in the data for
long enough,
but to the average person,
the layman,
it's a little bit different.
The global economy must feel like a
giant,
hulking mass that grinds against the
world unstoppable and on answerable to
the small problems of individuals.
So when your boss asks you to work
overtime but won't pay you for it,
you don't argue or demand to be paid
because how could an ant influence a
conversation between people or when you
ask for a raise and the boss threatens
to fire you,
you don't stick up for yourself because
no raise is better than no job.
Threats like these don't just function
on the level of individuals in many
ways.
It's how the entire American economy has
operated for almost 40 years.
That's how you end up with a graph like
this which shows the wealthiest sliver
of society getting virtually all the
gains from economic growth,
siphoning money from the middle class
and the poor.
Take a step back from this in a
democratic system which extends the vote
to all citizens over 18.
It's hard to imagine how such a small
percentage of people could convince the
rest to perpetuate a system that does
this.
The truth is there's only one way to do
You have to create an economic theory
that makes the exploitation of the
people look like the solution to their
problems.
In other words,
you have to tell a story.
That's all the economy is.
It's a story that we tell ourselves,
a story that tells us what decisions to
make about our own resources.
So what if your story is that lowering
taxes on the rich,
especially on unearned income,
deregulating finance and privatizing the
public comments is like taking the
living economy out of the shade and into
the sun where it can flourish.
It's a pretty good story and in fact,
those are the basics of a story that
have animated our politics and our
economy since Ronald Reagan,
a story that has produced advocates and
presidents on both sides of the
political spectrum.
This story didn't help the middle class
or the poor,
not really.
Their wages haven't risen since we began
telling it,
but it did give the top one percent
greater access to and greater power over
all the best storytellers,
politicians,
academics,
and the media.
To change the economy,
you have to change the story.
A difficult thing to do,
considering how much power has
consolidated in the hands of so few,
but it's not impossible.
Take the minimum wage.
For example,
right now the federal minimum wage $7
and twenty five cents an hour.
That's about $15,000
a year.
In 1968,
the minimum wage was a dollar 60,
but when you adjust for inflation,
that number it all the way up to $8 and
fifty four cents an hour,
a dollar and twenty nine cents more than
it is today.
Meanwhile,
American worker productivity has never
stopped growing so much so that if the
minimum wage kept pace with
productivity,
it would have been $21 an hour by now,
so in the absence of federal action,
states have raised their own minimum
wages,
30 of which are higher than the federal,
most notably of all,
California just voted to raise its
minimum wage to $15 an hour by 2022.
That's something that was unthinkable
even five years ago in New York did the
same a short time after this movement.
The fight for 15 is part of a new story.
The story that believes in finally
growing the wages of the middle class so
that their collective purchasing power,
their demand can grow the economy
organically in a way that's not
dependent on speculation or financial
bubbles.
It believes in regulating the abuses of
Wall Street and making what should be
accessible to all education and
healthcare.
Part of our comments,
again,
there are no shortage of articles.
Politicians or studies showing,
for example,
that increasing the minimum wage is a
risky gamble or a job killer.
No shortage of doomsday forecasting that
prices would rise,
but remember that this status quo has a
huge interest in maintaining itself just
like a boss.
It uses threats to keep the society in
line.
Here's a Meta analysis of pretty much
every single minimum wage study,
the closer to the top,
the more precise and accurate the study
is,
and this shows that all the most
comprehensive analysis of the minimum
wage show that it would have little to
no negative effect on employment lows,
and yet it could raise the incomes and
standards of living of millions in
places where the minimum wage has
increased like Seattle prices haven't
skyrocketed.
Instead,
people are actually able to buy the
things they've consistently increased
their productivity to produce.
Minimum wage increases,
won't solve all the problems in the
economy,
not even close,
it's just one thing,
but the victory of an idea that runs
counter to the dominant ideology is
hugely significant.
Otto von Bismarck said that politics is
the art of the possible,
but I think that sometimes invoking the
possible is just another tactic and
other negotiating strategy,
another threat used on behalf of the
status quo.
To restrict the movement of alternative
ideas,
the story of this economy has been
laboring under for 40 years,
is failing.
People feel it even if they don't know
why.
A moment like this is when alternative
ideas can populate the center.
So maybe it's time to stop leading with
what is possible and start leading with
what's right.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching the.
I have to thank Nick Hanauer who helped
me research and sponsored this video.
He's been an activist in the fight for a
$15 minimum wage movement for a long
time.
He's written a lot about it and he's got
a great ted talk too,
which I'll link to over there.
Definitely watch that.
Um,
if you want help pledge to this channel,
you can go right below here to my
patrion pledge,
a dollar or $3 per video.
Everything helps.
You guys have been incredible.
And um,
and I'll see you guys next Wednesday.